the ring - once again starred Naomi
Watts but this time around it was
directed by the man who made the
original two Japanese films Hadiya
Nakata they brought him back to make the
Americanized version of the Ring - which
was a follow-up to the very successful
first film but in no way remakes the
Japanese Ring - this is an entirely new
story that goes in a completely
different direction from the first
American remake of the Ring as well as
the two Japanese films not just in story
and plot but also in quality cuz this
movie sucks
once again rachel played by Naomi Watts
and her son Aiden are plagued by Samara
this girl who created this cursed
videotape with all of her thoughts and
feelings it was her attempt to have her
horrific past and terrible upbringing
spread this movie was actually so boring
that it took me three different devices
to watch it I watched it on my Amazon
video account because you can get it in
HD on Amazon video but there's no
blu-ray so I was like okay I'll watch
John Amazon video because you know HD
I'm a movie stub so whatever I start out
on my 65 inch TV in the basement about
40 minutes in I get bored out of my mind
and I switched to my phone upstairs then
I get bored again and I switched to my
TV in my room I took me three devices to
finish this movie across an entire day
this film strangely has barely anything
to do with the first one there's a
strange force subplot about Rachel being
a terrible mom people are seeing bruises
on Adan that in reality are caused by
this paranormal event but people think
Rachel's abusive there's a strange
subplot with her boss that she works
with played by Simon Baker that goes
nowhere that's completely useless to
describe the plot this movie is actually
kind of hard because it goes in so many
different directions and it feels so
jumbled and it feels so muddled I
watched this movie originally back in
the day and I just watched it last night
in preparation for this review so I've
seen it twice and I can't tell you what
it's about I really I don't know the way
this movie chose to tell its story is
very confusing things happen scary
things
mara appears in mirrors she jumps out of
bathtubs she grabs people on the wrists
a lot
she takes possession of young Aden all
of these things happen and we understand
what we are seeing but we just don't
really understand the world that it's in
it's difficult to comprehend the rules
of this world like what is really going
on in this movie how do these things
link up especially in the way the film
ends it's like this strange
hallucinatory hypnotic vision that
Rachel's character is having and it's
supposed to tie things together and then
we get like the dialogue that we need
that makes us feel calm the kind of
dialogue where a character will be like
is it over and someone else will go yeah
it's over and then we as the audience go
okay it's over because they said it was
so I guess I guess everything's fine now
what what the fuck just happened
I mean it the ring too is a very
confusing movie a lot of things that
take place in this movie really don't
make sense and as I said it is so bogged
down with a huge amount of pointless
subplots that lead to nothing and a
performance by a young child actor who
really has an obsession with blinking
something that was very startling about
the first ring was the way people would
die when they see the tape and then
seven days later Samara comes for them
their face is hung open it looks very
disturbing in the idea of someone's
heart stopping from fear and that
happening to your face is a very
frightening thing and it was something
that definitely scared me a lot the
first time I saw the first movie in this
movie the ring face as it was eventually
coined is funny like it's actually
hilarious and that's really bad because
by far that's one of the most creepy
things in the first movie was the way
these characters would die and in this
film it's just it's funny when she opens
up the bag and the kids like duh and
then when she finds Simon Baker in the
car and he's like duh it's funny it was
directed very poorly and that leads me
to my biggest issue with this movie and
something that actually hurts because
the original director came back to
direct these movies and that's awesome I
really like the fact that the studio did
that that DreamWorks actually got in
contact with this guy and was like do
you want to make this movie and it got
made
he did a very poor job when you compared
to Gore Verbinski's excellent editing
and very tense direction in the first
film this movie has none of that
sequences in the opening scene that are
supposed to be startling and effective
just look very cheap and mundane and
really the entire film comes off like
that even Naomi Watts is not very
convincing in this movie it's very
unfortunate something else I loved about
the first movie was that it had all
these little hints and very subtle
things visually that made you feel like
you are watching something off-putting
or strange this movie has only one thing
like that that I could find and it's
crescent moon imagery every time the
moon is on screen it's always a crescent
moon when Rachel is in the well and she
looks up the crescent moon shape is
there again those little visual moments
are fun but they just don't really add
to anything and they don't make you feel
anything
this movie was unfortunately nowhere
near as scary as the first one nor as
scary as the Japanese films it was
boring
mostly poorly acted the story didn't
really make any sense at all the only
positive that I can find from this movie
are a few fine performances mostly from
Naomi Watts and Simon Baker they were
fine in this movie it has none of the
scares none of the drama and none of the
tragic elements that made the other ring
movie's special I'm going to give the
ring to a d-plus well guys the newest
rings film is coming out very soon let's
hope it's better than this movie you
guys are the best look forward to that
review very soon thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes